Jed York the CEO of the san francisco
for donors who's very active on Twitter
I follow Jed at Jed York tweets out Jim
is my coach we are trying to win a SB
not a personality or popularity contest
any more questions any more questions
Jed York is on the phone line Jedi have
questions thank you for joining the rich
eyes and show how are you Jed it I'm
good if I had to show to plug like Dan
I'd try it but but I'm glad that I could
be on your show you've got a team to
plug you got a team to plug this one
that's that's three and two you got that
right we're we're playing pretty good
yesterday was a good day okay so it's
fun to watch yesterday yeah and and I'm
sure it must be wonderful seeing in this
new beautiful stadium it's remarkable
that even able to turn a shovel in the
state of California but all of that said
there's a lot of people shoveling dirt a
top Jim Harbaugh the report again Jay
Glazer saying that that there's no way
he's returning even if you win a Super
Bowl that it you say that's
categorically not true that
categorically not true I mean Jim's our
coach I said it clearly yesterday I mean
both of us addressed it at the beginning
of the season we're going to sit down
and talk about his contract right after
the season is over and I think both of
us came to that conclusion it doesn't
make sense to try to negotiate a
contract in the middle of a season we're
focused on getting back to and winning
the Super Bowl and that's that's really
the only thing that's on anybody's mind
here but you here at so many different
ways Jed different reports from people
in our in my business the media business
you hear it in over and over again it's
happened every three years like a mad
lib you just need to change the weeks
and the times that that he's he's
rubbing people the wrong way and it's
not sustainable where where does this
come from then jedd you know I mean
interns about sustainability every coach
will will move on at some point and I
don't think Jim is at that point we
we've had a great relationship here
we've had three pretty successful
seasons
so far and you know by 49er standards
unless you're holding the Lombardi
Trophy up it's it's not truly a
successful season and I think we all
know that we all understand that and
I've tried to explain this to people the
the wrongness of getting close but not
getting there and not not actually
attaining the ring you know it it it's
hard to start from zero every season
after you after you have a long long
road going through the playoffs you know
having a gut-wrenching loss last year in
seattle it's hard to hit reset and I
mean I think you start to see our
players hitting their stride and I think
you saw that a little bit yesterday it's
hard to really hit that reset button but
i think that's that's what we've been
able to do and make sure that we are
we're not focused on what happened or
what didn't happen the last three years
we're focused on how to make it happen
this year how would you categorize the
relationship between your coach and your
general manager very professional they
work very well together I think Jim does
a great job of letting Trenton the
scouts go out and find players we've
added some good talent to this team over
the last four or five years and you know
they they work together in that sense
where trends never been a coach he has
no aspirations of coaching I've been in
situations you know where where that was
a case here I wasn't working at the
49ers at the time but when you had a
former coaches your general manager it
that can be dicey you know that's not
how it is here you've got you know Jim
and Trent that work fairly well together
i think the results speak for themselves
and they're very professional with each
other and that's that's really all I can
ask for do you think that this sort of
because again I mean being professional
in your winning games there's no
question about that it just seems that
there there's a certain stage of I don't
know what the word would be turmoil is
too tough a word but that you know a
word that we would use in my old house
it would beat saurus there's also
there's there's there's a lot of angst
or there's a lot of tension a little bit
and that that Harbaugh may need that in
order to succeed which
you would you agree with that a session
yeah I think that's pretty fair to say i
mean that's that's how Jim in you know I
mean Jim Jim competed anything and
everything that he does and that
sometimes rubs people the wrong way but
he has it he has an amazing way to be
able to pull people together and find a
way to go win tough football games you
know put himself in a position to to
have his team have the most success and
he said something yesterday I'm probably
not going to get the quote right and he
said you know my job is to love my team
not for them to love me and and he truly
believes that you know they're there are
some people that don't like if everybody
in the room doesn't like them Jim isn't
one of those people you know Jim Jim
wants to make sure that he goes out and
finds a way to win and that's that's
what he's done and that's what he's done
just about everywhere that he's been as
a coach you know as a player it's kind
of hard to put losing seasons on one
player out of 53 but you know he's he's
found a way to win and just about
everything that he does how's the plans
for Super Bowl 50 going Jed it's good
it's good we we definitely have some
things to work through and you know it's
hard when you build a stadium to get
everything to work perfectly day 1 i'm
sure you see that when you build a set
yes things that aren't perfect day one
but that you work through them and and
by the time Super Bowl 50 is here it's
it's going to be it's going to be
amazing I think it's going to be the
best venue for a Super Bowl anybody has
ever seen and you got rid of the Roman
numeral because you can't have Super
Bowl L right you don't want an L with a
Super Bowl you got rid its your go ahead
I didn't get rid of the Roman numeral if
I got rid of the Roman numeral I think
my wife would have gotten rid of me Wow
was she from wrong he loves the roman
numeral okay she loved him but it's but
you're going with the 50 right cuz you
can't have you can't go you can't go
super with that wasn't me that was that
was the NFL's call okay well you also i
just i just want to be clear I'm not I'm
not condoning that decision by the
National Football League but but it
certainly wasn't mine because if it was
my wife would probably I had nothing out
Wow your wife serious about the role
minus murrells huh she is serious about
the roman numeral she loves the roman
numeral i can go ahead and crow about
Notre Dame I know you want to I know you
want i don't know i mean that's why i
think that's why you kept asking the
questions you just want Jim no hold on a
minute now I love my coach I love Brady
Hoke and I know he's going through a
tough times and it's dreadful what's
going on on the football field I I
personally have never met anybody with
more integrity and his integrity has
been questioned I believe it you know a
lot of michigan fans are tweeting me
they otherwise but but no i mean you
know a lot of their know Brady Hoke but
I've that's all I've heard or great
things about his character yes yes but
I'm Way too far removed to be able to
comment on that right now but go for
crow bottom crow bottom you want but I
think that's part of the discord with
Jim Harbaugh he's upset Notre Dame goes
and beats up on Michigan then we beat up
on Stanford you know it's just you know
it creates that's it that's the tension
oh man yeah okay well so wrapping up
there if Jim Harbaugh wins the super
bowl then then then what happens he's
still he's still around I mean I was
like I've said this all along I would
like for nothing else to be in the worst
possible negotiating position with him
very good Jedi really I appreciate your
support again I know they were on we're
streaming on the NFL now app I know
that's a big thing for you and owners
like Jonathan Lee way i watch anything
anymore Phil no no so I know it's very
important to you and your supportive of
this show and things that I've done over
the 11 years of the network I can't
thank you enough i appreciate it well
well I appreciate it rich I wish you the
best of luck and I was saying earlier
that the wide angle lens it looks like
you've got ray Donovan on your set so I
wanted to make sure that's it make any
false step what do you think law you
like the right Donovan analogy yeah you
know he's the voice of hard knocks so
I'm not lovely of Jed thanks appreciate
it complain have a great day guys